you
I like to think of innovation as as a
process the process of transforming new
ideas into tangible societal impact and
so it that means that it's not enough to
just have a new idea but it's really
important for that idea to make an
impact to scale to grow to touch many
people's lives certainly it can create
financial wealth but it also creates
social wealth social capital human
capital and so it's really important to
look at it from that whole perspective
right now we're in a very challenging
situation obviously and everyone's
wondering where the next jobs going to
come from and absolutely new Joe hubs
are going to have to come from new
businesses and new products and those
come from from new ideas so if you do
incremental innovation you might grow
have a little bit of economic growth but
it's the real fundamental groundbreaking
ideas that create whole new sectors
whether it's the internet or
biotechnology you're now green
technology water technology and there's
some real needs and challenges in the
world grand challenges that will also
only be solved with some serious
innovation a lot of people think that
economic downturn it's time to really
buckle down and look within and you know
there's not going to be any
opportunities and the reality is that
during an economic downturn that could
be some of the biggest opportunities for
individuals entrepreneurs and companies
in fact the majority of the Dow the
companies in the Dow were funded or were
founded in an economic downturn Disney
Cisco caterpillar tons of companies that
have really seized an opportunity and
part of that is because you don't have a
situation where everyone wants to get
into the game and everyone says oh it's
my turn to make a buck and they're not
really serious about the passion of
their idea it's really the best only
people that are really resourceful and
see a real opportunity and jump in there
probably are going to survive but it's a
real opportunity for those ideas to to
flourish and it's also in some ways
it might be more challenging to start a
company but at the same time it can be
easier because the rents are cheap the
talents cheap you don't have as much
competition others jumping into the
market so there's some positive sites
for the entrepreneur as well
universities have historically been a
huge source of innovation for the
country and in fact there was a study
that was done recently a couple years
ago that looked at the rd 100 which is
the hundred most significant innovations
of the year as defined by our d magazine
and what was interesting they looked
over the last 30 or more years of
historically speaking and if you look at
about 30 years ago 20 25 30 years ago
about seventy percent of the most
significant innovations had found their
initial idea in a private in the private
sector an industry had funded it
exclusively and now it's completely
flipped so seventy percent our fund are
founded or developed using public
funding universities and federal labs so
that's an example of our demonstration
of something that people have been
saying for a little while now is that
you just don't have the bell labs in the
zero xerox parks in the industry to be
doing some of the really fundamental
research that's going to be creating the
breakthrough ideas of the next of the
next generation so universities they
really form a nexus of innovation
ecosystems and they they're the source
of the real breakthrough ideas that
we're going to be needing an innovation
one thing that very passionate about and
I think is really important for people
to understand every year in this country
we spend taxpayers a federal government
spends 50 billion dollars a year on
university research and that's
absolutely critical because that's where
the the new ideas are going to be coming
from in the real breakthroughs however
you spend 50 billion dollars a year on
research but we spent almost nothing on
the programs and universities to get
those ideas out into the market despite
that we still there's a study by the
association of university technology
managers autumn the latest study from
2008 they do a survey every year show
that there have been over 600 new
products that are developed that were
developed that year and almost 600
startup so spun out of university
intellectual property and there's about
3,300 University spinouts that are in
business today and so it's it's despite
the fact that we're not investing in it
it is happening but it's not happening
at nearly the rate and I've seen it with
my own eyes that there are things that
are sitting on the shelves and sitting
in the labs that are not seeing the
light of day and I believe that it's
really in large part because of that
there's a big gap between the university
in the market
well first you know what what is what is
that gap and a lot of people talk about
something called the valley of death and
it's primarily seen as a funding gap
there's some really interesting ideas in
the lab but just there they're a little
bit too far removed from from the
private sector is willing to invest in
it so we need to do a proof of concept
to show that these ideas will actually
work for specific market needs to
address to address specific market needs
and so that's that's one need and the
angel investors venture capitalists are
not filling that gap and I'm not sure
that it really isn't appropriate for
them to be filling that gap because
these are not ready first to be a
start-up or a of our product yet but
it's also a cultural gap so in the
university the other motivations are how
do I support my students and how do i
how do I get the next research grant how
do I raise my reputation as the expert
in this field whereas in the private
secretary of course it's about revenues
profits and and so and those are
completely appropriate motivations for
the two groups and so another way i like
to think about it is in academia
surprises are good but in industry not
so much so it's definitely a big
cultural gap and then what we're what
what we don't want to do is we don't
want to try to turn academics into
business people and we certainly are not
going to get business people to try to
become academics but what we need to do
is to help connect them and help connect
the two cultures and enable them to
learn about each other and and what
motivates thumps that they can speak
each other's language and so it's it's
really about the bridging and about
about teaching
so we've had some you know across the
country have been some success successes
with innovation centers and proof of
concept funds and a greater focus on
transfer and entrepreneurship education
and so I have a proposal that I wrote
with a support of many others that is
called the impact proposal was at the
urging of the White House Office of
Science and Technology Policy they said
how can we help bridge this gap and the
idea behind it is a to start with a
pilot program 20 million dollar pilot
program where a handful of universities
would be selected to develop these
programs innovation programs to provide
small proof-of-concept grants fifty a
hundred thousand dollars to faculty and
students to provide mentoring for the
faculty and the students and provide
some educational resources and
connections to the outside community and
really build ecosystems around these
centers it's built on you know it's
worked before but to help build it into
a best practice that others can build on
and ultimately hopefully the federal
government would see that there is a
value incredible value that would pay
back many many fold that will be worth
investing in this process the present
and the the local capacity around the
universities of the universities would
serve as the nexus of these innovation
ecosystems I think that universities are
particularly well-suited to serve as
that nexus because not only our
universities creating some of the most
exciting groundbreaking technologies and
ideas already but we're also incredibly
situated with you know hundreds of
thousands of alumni that want to get
involved we have brands local interest
in the local community and we're also
really good convenors because we don't
have any private interest or any
particular bias and and we're also
incredibly good at educating people so
we that's that would be that's a really
powerful role
and up until now universities have you
know the main focus of a university is
the creation and dissemination of
knowledge so this is it this is an
extension of that already important very
important mission to the point where how
do we disseminate that knowledge to make
greater societal impact
well um in the 2008 autumn survey they
surveyed all the universities and saw
the spin outs that have been created out
of university intellectual property then
and this does not include to be clear
either the student startups and other
startups that may be created not based
on intellectual property that the
seventy two percent of startups that
spin out of universities stay local
within the state of the university so it
has a huge economic impact and it also
because of that ecosystem feeling indie
can enough seen it happen when I when I
was at MIT and now that I'm at USC to
have these and promote the ideas that
are within the university in a
programmatic fashion it's a very group
it's a very successful way or very
effective way of getting alumni involved
and getting the local business community
involved within the university and come
together and then meet each other so its
no balls and it just becomes much more
it becomes a really vibrant community
many people have asked me whether is
this just appropriate for elite
universities and and I think that's
absolutely not not the case because any
any university either that does research
or has students that are have some sort
of entrepreneurial inclination would
really be better would be well served to
be trying to increase that that type of
an activity in the case of a smaller
university that might have a smaller
research budget they can they can band
together to create a greater critical
mass so for example a friend of mine
who's heading up tech transfer at
Brandeis University in Boston she's
working with other universities in that
area to create a consortium so that they
can work together and have that have a
much larger research base to attract
more individuals to that to that group
so that there's definitely opportunities
for any university to participate in
this sort of activity the reality is
there's been studies that show that the
more basic and the more groundbreaking
the research the more effective
transferring innovation there is from
the University so I would encourage
those universities to not give up the
roots of doing some really basic
research because I think there's a bit
of a temptation to say oh well we only
have a small research base let's try to
move as much of it into applied research
as possible and I think that that's
absolutely not would not be the right
approach if you're really trying to make
some groundbreaking innovations